I've been in here for four hours my ribs
are showing I don't know about y'all but
I'm out I wouldn't recommend that way
well thanks to your botched Berlin job
you all made Interpol's top ten most
wanted list top ten mm-hmm that's all
right
well not you Roman what do you mean you
just missed the cut you're number eleven
so um I missed ya that's impossible
what number did they come in at six
eight nine ten she's 10 mmm that's
impossible there's no way she's a 10 oh
she's definitely a 10 these guys are
taking this person you were only
supposed to create a diversion Roman
that was complete destruction what you
want for me I'm Roman Pearce man it's
what I do
Chris to Phase two what's phase two
pounds away
[Music]
Oh
you know what I like about you dawn
you're a genuine outlaw but you're
assembling the hell of a job brother
when we get back to the base beers on me
he's about to go up against the only
thing they can't handle you did you ever
think you'd betray your family the way
you did today Dominic Toretto just
turned on us oh well well you look at
that I don't know why he's doing this
but that wasn't done she's the very
definition of AI tech terrorism and now
she's working with your guy I think I
found my team this should be interesting
[Music]
wanna play like that
this is impossible which is why they're
gonna need a little help I will beat you
like a Cherokee drum longer than I
expected
if you gotta catch Dom you guys are
gonna work together surprise I just fell
in love I've been waiting for this we
got a tank this row I don't know if the
old DOM is in there I don't give a damn
I'm taking you down so right okay let's
play
why are they shooting at me I don't know
maybe because you're always laughing
[Music]
we go
[Music]
see we're gonna need a bigger truck
[Music]
you're gonna turn your back on family
[Music]
you